Canadian outlet I have to ask about
legend Queen Shania Twain it's funny I
always tell people like in what world is
Shania Twain play your mom you know
animate and honestly she's incredible
and just to see her portray my mom in
such a sweet way was was a huge huge
just blessing to watch so she's awesome
what was it like meeting it had Jim in
her before or was this the first time
you had met her first time and so just
to with all the actors I mean they they
I don't know they put their heart into
it and like she's unless she did the
part it's because she believed that it
didn't have to do the film you know I
mean a mushishi night when he didn't
have to do it you know but the fact that
she believed in the film and bleeding
the story and decided to be a part of it
was huge um what was it like revisiting
this part of your life in such a visual
way you know I'm sure it lives with you
always but just sort of seeing it laid
out that's exactly what it's in a visual
way that was the difference because I've
shared my story I wrote a book clash to
believe that kind of shared and that
personal aspect of it it's different
because it you feel like you're reliving
it more and I had lots of moments of
during the filming of breaking down and
having to leave the filming you know a
moment during the screening where I've
shared the story a lot because it's such
a it's a beautiful story but it's hard
I'm watching it and I had to leave it's
the first time I watched the film when I
left and I I just lost it my wife let me
kind of lose it for a while she came in
and just hugged me and we cried we
walked out my kids you know my two girls
came and we all hugged each other and I
said dad watching this film it's hard
knowing that if I knew it that somebody
went through it it would be hard
Washington to know my dad went through
it makes it that much more difficult and
and we just cried and I said but you
wouldn't be here right now and it kind
of gave us this beautiful bonding moment
together
that I can't describe and it feels so
special did you have any hesitation
about bringing this story to like you
know to the screen I mean yeah because
you know that it's a huge responsibility
and it's a lot of emotion you know and
so I don't take this lightly amount of
Psych yeah I'm gonna share my story you
know I've never been like that because
it's not just a story it's the hardest
part of my life and so I don't take it
lightly you know how to think through it
and kind of pray through it and say am I
supposed to do this
and honestly it wasn't easy has it been
easy but the end result is so beautiful
and so moving and I feel like people's
lives gonna be touched because of it
it's worth it you know it is worth it
what is something that you hope people
take away or feel whenever they walk out
of the film yeah so I'm very unashamed
but in my faith because that's what got
me through everything and so I do hope
because no matter who you are or what
background you come from or part of the
world you're in pain is a universal
thing we all experience it and so some
people might be going okay I'm
experienced is paying what do I do now
and I'm happy to be able to say the
solution on Iran too is Jesus and not
everyone's gonna want that or want to
hear that and that's okay but how could
I not share that because that's been
what's been my comfort in my everything
and I want to share with the world that
to me he's he was the answer to that and
so I love it I'm so excited